Dallas Cowboys playing the Philadelphia
Eagles this Sunday in Dallas
what should the bet be what should what
should black blue win what's your J win
I mean like give people examples this is
very open-ended right Bobby J hardcore
gay stuff on the table it's very
progressive things that where we have to
go away for several days to do it I
would say has some sort of mountain
climbing activity possibly as Sundance
and sort of wife swap your wife's like
maybe like a mustard or a horrible
cheese
[Music]
it's the bonfire Comedy Central radio
series sex 795 I'm Dan Soder that's big
Jay oakerson coming in studio right now
new special coming out January 4th at
11:00 p.m. Eastern on comedy central
part of stand-up month Ron Funches
giggle fit January 4th hi Ron how you
doing dude good how are you guys doing
oh you got headphones on headphones good
yeah it looks like 2 Chainz of
headphones yeah your dual wielding yeah
yeah before we get into talking to Ron I
want to thank Isaac Harris who came out
in Boston and gave us that that duster
that Marber old jean jacket Mauro Myles
Myles legit Marlboro Myles jean jacket
which is pretty hard to get I
got them at Barbara's watch yeah wait
that's a marble miles from smoking or
you just buy it online make up your own
answer there's more fraud you bought it
online I tried once you know people are
like hey try this and yeah and a lot of
times people are like you know if you're
getting smoking pot yeah it helps you
yeah I've heard like well I mean I
smoked cigarettes for a long time and
that was the thing I was like I remember
my friends be like it's better after you
get high yeah and I believed it because
the cigarettes yeah I was like it is but
it's really not I never liked spliffs or
anything like that do you turn down
spliffs know like if now yeah because I
have Wheaton that's great yeah but I'm
saying like even if I kind of like when
someone has a former
cigarette smoker what someone has a
spliff I'll be like oh I'll rush
so yeah so you never it was one
cigarette and you're like this yes
welcome
but you cigarette was a cigarette
my first ascent of Malaysia my first was
a menthol your first one was more like
very harsh
yeah it was Marlboro yeah I think
marbles are usually the the first
cigarettes for a lot of kids oh yeah
Christine went Marlboro Reds you just
dig right into like the harshest
cigarette that's too much cowboy killer
my dad smoked merit American I was my
stepfather as a full-strength newport it
is funny again my parents from a time
worse that's even I now make the the
menthol cigarettes being a black thing
joke yeah it's a great thing that
everyone gets but I'll tell you my
father smoked cools cool my mom smoked
cools filter kings and my stepfather
smoked Newports in Newport you want to
know real underappreciated menthol
cigarette Salem's they're out when I
started smoking that's where I started
smoking my friend would steal cigarettes
from his mom and his stepdad before the
bus arrived before the bus stop in
seventh grade and it was always a
Marlboro light and a salem light and you
had to pick which one and if he
got the Marlboro you're like yeah I
don't have to smoke glass that's
what I won that comedy contest
Salem cigarettes sponsored years ago
Salem or bee contest and when I won they
sent me a case yeah of cartons of Salem
lights and the box was so cool it was so
cool the Box open sideways I was the
sliding out slide out box and I'd never
smoked cigarettes before I tried
Newports when I was younger yeah I never
smoked as an adult and at like 22 years
old or something it's when you started I
forget that you started smoking my
girlfriend of me broke up I was like I
want to look cool hanging outside of
comedy clubs I don't perform anywhere I
really or get up very much so I'm gonna
sit outside of the comics and be cool
and
smoked Lukoil in the beginning it's hard
to think that I was smoking I was
actively smoking to make sure that I was
I had to get a few in you know like the
practice lawyers when I was practicing
for and then it becomes a time we have
to stop yourself from just chaining it
non-stop yeah but there was a time when
I was like alright four exits from here
I'll I'll smoke another cigarette yeah
that's that was your training yeah we're
on how old are you and you start smoking
weed 16 you were 16 did you do training
because that's what we do is the thing
you need to train on it's the thing that
you like smoke and you're like you get
to high and you're like I can do that
better next time
no I just I mean I the first time I
smoked I went to my friend's trailer and
they had a little wizard bong and and
then they had a bunch of red vines which
became very delicious and then like
whatever show we were watching it was
the best show I had ever seen
so yeah the next day I was like yeah
I'll do that
I remember Pizza Hut the first time I
got really really high when I was a
teenager I went home and all I wanted
was a Pizza Hut pizza at like 10:00 in
the morning my mom's boyfriend was like
why are you why are you pushing this get
a pizza on a Bigfoot it was yeah
but it was I thought I was hoping the
guy my mom wasn't a yeah I
don't know maybe thought I could respect
you as a man but I guess I can if you
won't do 10 a.m. Pizza Pizza Hut yeah
your mom's boyfriend would be down with
that's an ally you yeah setting
them up I wanted to be like huh you're
an easy way to make him the cool guy I
mean dude I was handing Joe a pass to be
the yeah I was your mom
you're like let's get half a pizza and
play Sega Genesis I mean like I'm never
leaving do you want my last name I feel
a kinship with you hey dude do you want
to watch old wrestling and eat pizza
place a yeah I don't know son oh my god
am i banging your mom - ow
[Music]
I think it's like children should be
seen and not heard like I am 16 I didn't
smoke anything weed when I was young at
all when was the first time you got high
first time I smoked weed I was probably
18 or so okay that's not but not even
that but I also didn't uh I didn't
everything the first time I try it
doesn't really do very much for me well
you lose the DMT DMT had nothing it
didn't work have you done DMT at all no
I mean I haven't done many things I'm
mostly pot and mushrooms or my things
I'm allergic to alcohol drink that and
then I have like addiction and my family
from like my dad and says yeah always it
was like I'm not gonna do like coke and
stuff because I'm like I'm gonna love it
that's why we said to I know my thing
was like what if I the two lines I ever
did they two lines total yeah one per
time two different times didn't do
really do anything to me and then I was
like people god no you gotta try it like
this you like you know what now I never
find out it's great same thing I'm like
if it's great the next week yeah you bet
I can do it once in a while no exactly
that's every weekend that's what it was
just like another convincing yourself to
do it one more time yeah I already do
that with cheese days couple fat lines
and you have that menthol looks like the
guy to get you on coke it's like
harmless innocent so we can drink a
little longer
I'm telling you man's gonna help you
study college coke face and ease the guy
was a party this mom's mansion but he
never leaves his mom's bedroom the whole
time he's out he just kind of holds camp
in there with a couple of chicks tell
them to go away
anyway Tiffany Molly you guys ever
kissed before it was something that I it
was a thing that I was like if I do this
if I do the training like you said with
smoking cigarettes are you like one more
cigarette before the exit for me
cigarettes I had my first cigarette
behind I think it was like a dollar
store right on it was called makrooh
gel's
Kazan chambers and handed an Aurora we
laugh but that is a great case they
named it that thinking that like these
rubes they're gonna think it's a name
yeah no point my god I wish I was
shopping more at make fruit broke Steve
I'll say this for the amount of times
I've said Walmart in my life I wish I
would have said Nick frugal more I wish
it would have been like I'll make fruit
I'm going with frugal zits yeah I think
frugal is a billion-dollar industry
there behind him accrue goals and we
smoked a cigarette and I remember the
first couple dragon was like this I was
12 and I was like this sucks and then
after the next couple two I was like
yeah I do this now it was just like
something in my brain was like I do this
now and my friend Jason Pohl would steal
cigarettes from his parent we've said it
a bunch on this show but I'm just trying
to think of like I remember believing I
was too old to play we had this
conversation before to play with toys
yeah action figure and having to stop
myself I went after like probably months
to a year of not playing with GI Joes
yeah I went in bought two and I was like
they didn't even they changed the design
a little bit even in that year yeah and
I didn't really like it anyway which is
excuse my like I'm done getting these no
more of these at all but I don't know
but it's crazy for me to think that at
the same time that Dan was playing with
GI Joe not GI Joe's WWF Hasbro figures
when I play with those knots yeah
they're great they did the reissues with
new superstars yeah at the retro but I
what he's saying is when I was in
seventh grade I used to have like my
ring out and all of my wrestlers and
then on commercial breaks of wings or
doogie howser I got side spokes
a child soldier make sure I play as
tails off the vent could do it a
thousand times amateur
I'm not lying where I'm saying you're
kind of accurate yeah because I used to
have to hide my cigarette butts because
I was 12
yeah but I used to get really bad head
rushes cuz I was a child so I
would you know I remember smoking head
wasn't done development you know what it
was bright get all woozy and nauseous I
was like oh man this is bad but then
yeah I don't know I just love to smoke
one or another one I'm so bad how old
would your mom I rode my bike home so I
was like 14 it's huge like whatever no
no she was fury so how long did you
hide it from her about two years but I
wasn't so you're 16 no I quit smoking
from when I was about 14 and a half to
16 I just stopped smoking and then but I
got caught when I was 14 cuz I came home
we used to hang out I've told stories
about this at this town house we're
gonna sue at yeah the lawless Society
he's just lawless this girl's mom was
like achieved I think she was a
prostitute but she would just you know
she was a massage therapist she didn't
charge dance yeah so I was in there
Boston over here down in the basement
and like it was all these kids drinking
40s and smoking weed and you know
smoking cigarettes I was one of
the the nerdier ones so I was just
smoking cigarettes an occasional smoking
weed but I went home and my mom came
downstairs and I didn't know she's gonna
come downstairs and I was getting a
glass of juice in the kitchen and she's
like you smell like cigarettes and I was
like oh yeah we're auras house she goes
come here I was like huh she goes
breathe breathe into my mouth and I was
like I did or I breathe in just
breathe out you know keep sucking she
was like you you were smoking
cigarettes and then she woke up her
boyfriend Joe who was clearly drunk and
he was just like he has everybody but he
asked a lady the whole thing's
guy so I said then they went to bed I
could my parents smoked my mom instead
pop smoke but I could could you as you
have a household that was permissive it
seems like you'd be like really poor or
well-off in a way where you could be
unsupervised yeah and my mom and my
family were right on that bubble we
didn't live like in a ghetto but we were
real close to it so we were always my
mom was like she would take us to
museums and take us to school
after-school programs really try to keep
us away from what we were working on we
were broken unsupervised for sure but I
didn't roll with many packs of people
that were like gonna get into the real
trouble at all the kids my choice of
friends was not very I mean they were
kids who smoked and stuff like that yeah
I was very naive like I you know one
time I went at because they lived in
South Side Chicago so it's not very safe
area in this park that my mom would drop
us off and sometimes wouldn't be that
safe sometimes gangs would meet up there
yeah I'm going in the library to go get
you know a new cheesy adventure and
they there's like a gang having a
meeting in there in the library library
which is not like nobody can yell out
nobody can blurt out you have to stay
quiet
dude that is a way that's almost a way
to bring order with like the gang
members that thought of that it was
ahead of the curve he goes because guys
I've looked into it if we don't bring
weapons we can meet at the library yeah
yeah whispering they're like just in the
middle of a reading room in the library
yeah because Jaguar I don't want this
guy's nuts dude that is hilarious
to walk into the library but the moment
what's the realization where you walk in
and you're like what's this oh my god
this is a gang having a meeting yeah I
mean you know Billy oblivious so I'm
just just reaching for books and then
I'm like oh you guys are you guys don't
seem like you got books you don't seem
happy to be here or that I'm here yeah
yeah yeah just walk it into one of those
meetings and you're like everyone's
upset that I'm standing here right now I
am so sorry
Ronald the break was football team was
banished go go bears that Khalil Mac
trade unbelievable big deal
I think the Bears are their playoff team
this year I'm really hopeful that we can
beat the Rams this week me too if I knew
how to before but if someone could reach
out to bookies that contact yeah you
just tell you all these crazy things
because yeah I just take a 35% cut that
standard yeah he goes well basically
what happens is you give me $50 but
you're only betting twenty-five of it so
if you want to bet fifty give me $100
sounds like square biz this is how those
casinos are so rich yeah
betting gets a slippery slope have you
ever watched someone get too into sports
betting cuz it yeah I've watched the
other ones get too into it but I've also
I've never seen I've never myself
collected money from a bookie one of the
oh I like our actual bookie I've never
had I've had a friend become and then
not become a bookie wait why does he
couldn't keep up right out of mony yeah
really dude I mean I watched this guy
lose his hair over games dude the man I
was with a buddy at a bar when rg3 was
at baylor and we're at a bar watching
his bowl game with like his RG c RG
Three's Heisman season he's at Baylor my
buddy's super into the game and he's
from Colorado Mike why the do you
care about this Baylor game he's like I
have $5,000 on it you're like what the
and he's like yeah I took the
spread we're at this bar I'm like you
put $5,000 on his he's not a
rich guy I'm like why are you doing this
he's like I don't know I just find I'm
into it now I'm in deep like I'm betting
a lot and you're like five grand you
want a ball game that's crazy a
girl they want to do it it's wrong
kicked up he goes what's your buddy's
number
my buddy Little J his ex-girlfriend's
stepfather looked like Kenny Rogers and
worked for a book year was a bookie I
don't remember but whatever it is all of
our buddies not me because I'd really
gamble like that at all but they all got
way into I talk
like Paul having the pawn sell
stuff yeah sometimes have a ton of money
like buy a used car with you know
teenagers so you buy a used car with a
couple grand you won one week and then
the next week you'd go buy a system to
put in it a sound system and the next
week you have to sell the sound system I
mean I'm no exaggeration so but it was
all like in the realm of five grand or
less but to teenagers that's you might
as well say a million dollars I mean
five thousand dollars does yeah I swear
to you the first time my back has to
five thousand dollars was a memorable
moment of my life and it was way too
late like suppose you two felt this
about 10 to 15 years yeah you're like
man I feel good about this and because I
shouldn't so have you ever hang out what
just maybe I remember when I was really
broke hanging out with one of my married
friends who wasn't as broke he was
married and they both had kind of stable
lives and he left his ATM receipt in the
ATM and we're leaving are you receipt
they looked at it and it was like he had
something like 3200 dollars in savings I
was like with a rich guy was gonna say
that Kenny Rogers guy though when
everybody got into him deep yeah started
he would try to come like do drive-by
intimidation his rolls window down slow
yes he'd pull up next to us in a car I'd
be in the car with a buddy and he would
lower the window and there's a guy who
looks like Kenny Rogers would be like
boys I noticed you're doing a lot of
driving around and uh not coming by to
giving my money and do once they just
realized he had nothing more than that
to do yeah they would just start being
like you Gus or whatever stay was
slowly little eventually just and by the
way my buddy was still actually two of
my buddies bang the staff daughter and
but they just kept disrespectfully not
paying him back and they just found that
there's nothing he's not he wasn't
affiliated that's crying he was just
doing it for of big money yarder one
person just so he could you know you
guys want a mess well yeah that's what
you got to put you guys spill some blood
so problems you can see this guy wasn't
the blood spill or Kenny Rogers he goes
he starts every sentence with how you
doing yeah Kenny Rogers I got a real
Kenny Rogers thing
right now yeah it seemed like he really
was good you guys are really letting me
down
he emotionally intimidates you yes you
guys expected more come on boys
not fair man's game I'm not mad I'm
disappointed without you a man of your
word
apparently a man's word means diddly
squat around here apparently the money
means more to you keep it don't forget
you took the Panthers five and a half
ambling happened online at one point my
buddy had WebTV and figured I had a
gamble through that but that was it was
weird you were gambling through webtv
but it was still like a guy's gonna come
to your house about this really it
wasn't like I collect it wasn't done
through credit card stuff right out of
the gates it was just like it was a
Craigslist for gambling is that a good
way to put it you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah I never with gambling and
I'm glad it was like cocaine there's
worse things like if I get into this I
will get I'll care about a
Pacers bucks game at 1:00 in the morning
that I shouldn't care yeah I've never
gambled money that would change my life
ever I think I definitely told that
story of that guy whose couch I lived on
when I moved to Hoboken was a buddy of
mine and he worked on Wall Street and he
gambled in a way that was like a very
Wall Street II because I knew him in
college and he was like he could just
stay on my couch in Hoboken and I would
watch him it was the Florida Ohio State
national championship game he put 500
down on Florida or on Ohio State they
were losing he put a thousand down and
then it just kept climbing until that
night he was betting $3,000 on a WNBA
game and I was like that's crazy that
he's just like I gotta make it back I
gotta make him back and it was all in
one night when I came home I went out to
do like open mics and he came back and
he's like I'm I'm the
Bucks lost they're like all this
half zoo bird let me do you
understand Rebecca Lobo win it off but
it only feel like the juice only hits
you if you don't have a lot of money you
need money you gamble and you win money
what I don't understand is High Roller
gambling like Floyd Mayweather sort of
like that I don't understand the idea of
I've heard like a COO mean I'm not like
divulging he talked about it on on
Legion skanks one time but like
something and I'm making up the number
but it was something like astronomical
to me like I I lost by 17 grand
gambling at the tables and so and so and
you're like it's a blip on his radar but
it's also like it's also but the
difference is if you won 17 grand there
it's like in your world that's the
difference being buying like a an
amazing used car or a decent newcomer
twice the action of the of the the
adrenaline of is it gonna win it's not
less but if you can lose it what's that
it just hurts a lot less do you add the
adrenaline rush I think is still there
do you gamble like more money like heels
of like someone else's talented look
like well I mean anything life is proven
to me I don't really have a lucky route
so go ahead and just try work and get
money yeah and I also be in a big video
game player especially from a child I
was like oh I don't understand slot
machines you put quarter in it beeps and
you made something happens I could play
a video game I'm normal have fun yeah
and it's gonna be a great time why would
I it don't make sense interesting you
say that when I do any kind of lottery
like a scratch-off lottery I don't even
understand when people just have like
the give me a win for life and it's just
you just scratch it and see if you have
three matching things like I've only
ever done the bingo or the crossword
puzzles game for my two to five dollars
I'm gonna play a game oh did I get it
did I get bingo what if they mixed
gambling and video games they have they
have a bit what if I just made it up
right now and you guys are lying Time
Machine
turn off the goddamn cameras I just
invented something I have
undercut me take up what are you writing
down are you writing down my video game
gambling idea
you